so when you saw your dad in the industry
you would go with him right to he was an
editor he worked yeah I never really
actually understood his job where he was
an editor he didn't like lots of stuff
you know like when he they did laser
discs you know back there like the plays
of this company and I watched them go
through so many transitions because they
like laser disc was you know before DVD
it was around way before DVD and and
they would watch them do all that you
know they had caused when completed
commentaries you know so I met like you
know like hung out with like John
Wayne's kids like all these people since
I was little kid I was hanging out with
the crew namely Dougray Charlie
Chaplin's wife one of his ex-wives so I
got a great kind of film history lesson
from the time I was really young um what
and that that's what he would do he
would just you know he'd bring in a lot
of these kind of people and interview
them or put in like extras for like you
know like interviews with all these
people basically all the extra features
for laser discs and then at transitions
into DVD but I know throughout that he
did a lot of editing editing as well I
think yet a couple features I know
edited trailers and stuff like that so
he started bringing me and I this memory
first show me how to edit when I was
five by doing jump cuts to make somebody
just disappear he knows that's when I
first caught my attention like he showed
me how to disappear from a jump cut you
know like you know somebody's walking
just you know cut it to the nobody's
there and as a five-year-old I was like
what you know and then when I was seven
I started editing from like VHS to be a
chess player I'd hook it up and do it at
home but then when I was nine or ten he
started bringing me into image when he
said we're gonna image he started be
bringing me there because he was working
at Hollywood stars just something like
that for a TV show before that so there
I'll just hang out but then I guess he
felt I was old enough at nine or ten
that he surged show me how to actually
edit on the pro equipment they had you
know where he did all these kind of like
tape to tape was really editing on film
I'm sure was even harder but this was
definitely harder than um you know all
the adobe and final cut stuff I mean he
really had to take your time doing all
this stuff and that's how I learned at
it for for ten years I was editing there
until 2000 when I started then learning
how
do it on premiere at home you know so
from like 1992 2000 i think i was
editing all my stuff an image basically
you know on off hours I'd make him going
on the weekend because I can do it while
he was arguing so he'd have to like
bring me in on the weekend so I was
always making good he probably lived at
work there in those ten years because i
think im gonna weekend so i could edit
you know and he would just hang out and
do something else or catch up on work
you know what was it like to be around
that culture just of people that were
working on films passionate about them
do you see that same mindset today or
just a different world it seems like
it's a different quality of movies back
then there was more story based that's
just my opinion do you think you know as
a kid i'm already sir because i would oh
man i would talk a lot of people there
but i usually if I wasn't you know if I
was editing I was by myself or with him
and then if i was there you know like
after school or something i would just
go in one of the rooms it would actually
have me QC stuff like so my first
experience i think was entered to
dragging it was some bruce lee movie and
and so I brought down literally every
single scratch mark in the you know
which was constant you know because I
didn't realize that I was checking for
like digital you know hiccups I was
looking at all the scratch marks from
the actual film and marking every single
time code of all that but anyways that's
the stuff i would do is i would like
kind of you know i can be like a loner
off it's not like I had a good
understanding of um I guess how people
were with me I mean everybody was
friendly to me but it's like I don't
know I've always been a loner so it's I
just watched how it changed from the
laserdisc to the DVD and then and then
then they spent you know last couple
years he was there they'd have started
laying people off little by little and
finally he was the last group of people
to go you know before they just finally
had sold out to somebody else you know
because they're still around but it's
not the same company really and they're
doing now they're doing all these big
movies actually but um or you know big
star kind of driven movies but I think
it's actually all done like
you know they don't do it in-house
anymore they just have their company
that acquires and everybody else does
all that you know it was a huge company
they had a couple hundred people or
maybe several hundred people work in
there so I've watched all the
transitioning of that I had more
experience I guess watching that the
transition of this company because I
spent 20 years kind of yeah I said why
have 20 years of knowledge of I guys I
guess of how image worked you know going
from major laserdisc to not som heter
DVD to trying to build back up to major
theatrical but then tiny company and I
kind of watched all that happened so I
kind of got it I guess yeah I mean I
never really thought about that but I
got a good knowledge of that more than I
guess the kind of people more like I got
a understanding of how a certain company
went through two decades I guess
you